resident evil village is only weeks away
and we still can't seem to shut up about
the big ol tall vampire lady if you
exist on the internet you've seen the
fan art
the tweets pledging eternal love and
people just all around being
a little horny no king shame like love
at first sight though
looks can surely be deceiving and while
we're all a little busy fetishizing the
tall
fictional character what do we actually
know about her
so like some stocky admirer here's what
we've uncovered on lady
dimitrescu first she big she bad
she bombastic so yeah as a couple people
may have pointed out
she's tall which makes her the latest in
a long line of tall resident evil
villains
following jack baker who's reasonably
tall mr
x intimidatingly tall and nemesis a
towering pile of mincemeat
next thing you know rezzy online's big
bad guy will be jeffrey the giraffe
oh and she's a vampire that pale skin
and sophisticated outfit commands that
the world is aware
she is indeed a vampire but here's a
twist in an interview with ign
village's art director tomonori takano
said that the idea from the start was to
make a
quote bewitching vampire he said in the
early stages of planning we decided on
going with a castle and vampire motif
however we did not want to be
constrained by how vampires had been
portrayed
in various forms of popular
entertainment so in other words take the
sexy vampire trope and multiply it by
five literally as such capcom pulled
inspiration from several other places
including angelica huston's morticia
adams japanese urban legend hashuka
sama and 16th century hungarian
noblewoman and serial killer
elizabeth bathory suffice to say
dimitrisku definitely has
her own unique flavor as a ravenous
blood sucking creature of the night
or something closely approximated to one
at least we also know that the castle
we've been seeing is the tall lady's
house
in one trailer she's on the phone
talking to mother miranda who doesn't
pop up anywhere else
it could be that mother miranda is the
real mastermind behind all the strange
things going down in the village
who knows maybe she's the one who sire
the tall lady and in that case we thank
you mother miranda
during the phone call she mentions that
ethan winters has escaped
that full heisenberg and he's proven too
much for her
daughters to handle speaking of which
let's talk about the other sexy people
the three women dressed in black
who are presumably the tall lady's
daughters
are they her actual daughters or just
women she's churned
either way it appears they've inherited
some abilities as they can form
out of flies gone with the days of
vampires turning into bats that's some
old school vampire [ __ ] on with the days
a vampire is turning into a swarm of
flies
tall lady mentioned heisenberg the
aforementioned person that ethan gave
the slip to
when dimitrescu confronts ethan she says
you escaped
my little brother's idiot games did you
let's see how special you are
confirming that she has a sibling
relationship with heisenberg
the last thing we learn is that there is
some sort of ceremony happening soon and
the tall lady sounds like she's in
charge of making sure
it goes off without a hitch given that
ethan is in her castle to rescue his
kidnapped daughter we're guessing
turning a child into a vampire might
have something to do with it
alright that's all we know so far
hopefully this video quenched your
thirst
just a moment longer now you can go back
to drawing that tall vampire lady fan
art
this was curtain davina stay sexy
you